Alright, you're done.
Let's take a look at my solution.
For our first step,
we created a loader ID integer constant.
These just have to be unique for every
loader you're using in your activity.
Then we had forecast fragment
implement the loader manager loader
callbacks with type cursor,
as required by CursorLoader.
We added our three loader
callback functions.
For on CreateLoader we move
the ContentProvider query we had for
creating the cursor, and
use this to initialize the CursorLoader.
In odd load finish,
we swap the cursor in our
ForcastAdapter with our new loaded one.
In onLoader reset, we want to release
any resources that we might be using.
And that's it.
Let's run this, and
make sure it's all working correctly.
And, as you can see,
some fabulous weather.
This is actually using the loader, even
though it looks exactly like the output
from the last section that we completed.